love it when everyone chants that um
so charles and i really got into it on
the plane and around sunday number five
i realized
we should move in together you and
charles no you and me oh
yes that makes so much more sense
absolutely immediately let's do that
i love you
so much oh
i love you so much too
i love this so much
so i guess charles was listening to our
conversation yeah oop i'm gonna get this
hello jake peralta this is jimmy figgis
oh
uh
hey dog
you and ray holt took down my operation
now i'm gonna kill you both
later
dog
uh captain holt
blue skies
smiling at me
nothing but blue skies
do i see
morning greg
blueberry morning
but blue birds all day long
ah sir there you are we've been looking
everywhere kevin said he hasn't heard
from you all night yes i've been sitting
in my office wallowing in my
hopelessness and eating the saddest food
known to mankind
ice cream oh my god he's bridget jones
okay well it's time to put that aside
and pull out whatever food you eat when
you're happy dry beans sure look
we can still stop john kelly all we need
is some hard evidence oh he won't let us
anywhere near him or one police plaza i
know which is why i've assembled a team
of powerful allies in the nypd no that's
too risky how do you know they're not
loyal to john kelly because these people
aren't loyal to anybody
[Music]
i made a suicide squad i'm being
transferred to the public relations
office i'm leaving the nine-nine
effective immediately what the hell i
don't understand what the hell why are
you doing this what the hell i want to
say
it has been a pleasure to have worked
alongside all of you for the past 21 and
a half months
i'm sorry for getting so emotional
pretty consistent tone actually these
have been the
these have been the best
years of my career oh no this is new
and i know that
every one of you
give me everything you had
and i will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
me more
see
dismissed
sir
i'm coming with you thank you gina i'm
also coming not necessary
hey
hey thought i might find you in here i
just needed to process the captain's
news i feel so bad for him
so how you holding up
i don't know i'm still in shock
you
i'm basically handling it the way i
dealt with my dad leaving just
repressing the hell out of
it so a lot of change around here huh
jake the new captain's here
who do you think it's gonna be i have no
idea
that it's me
just hope i'm ready
wow
come on guys
i know you're sad but let's do our best
to make a good first impression here
smart good call jake you'll be up front
[Music]
okay
here we go
well we did it for a second there i
didn't think we were gonna pull it off i
knew we could
and we did to us oh what are you guys
celebrating terry was mad at us but we
didn't know what he was talking about
and he went away huge day yeah
oh
it's amy
hey girlfriend jake maura told me who
figgis has working for him in the fbi
yeah i already know who he is because i
just caught him special agent ryan
whelan also i did one full pull-up i'm
gonna be so buff when you get back cool
babe did you get the other guy what
other guy someone named bob anderson
bob
oh my god amy i have to go
bob is working for figgis what he must
have been the one who deleted all those
digital files andy tried to have wieland
killed but he helped us with the heist
and there was nothing about him in the
paper file yeah because that wasn't the
real file
i just need to put my return address on
it
yeah
there you go oh thank you
we have to call halt
come on captain pick up pick up
don't answer that raymond
and now i'm going to have to kill you
oh bob
mario why are you like this hey
so
i don't know if you noticed but ever
since i started those hormone treatments
i didn't notice anything
you said that way too quick i mean you
did cry at that one car commercial and
it wasn't even an emotional one it was
about towing capacity yeah
well i called the doctor to see if that
was a common side effect and apparently
it isn't
oh no
is everything okay yeah she did have one
guess as to what might be causing it
and um she was right
ames
are we having a baby we're having a baby
it happened congratulations once again
to jake and amy and now that everyone's
here i have an email that i need to open
all right weirdo not something we
usually announce to the squad it says if
you got the commissioner job oh my god
he was too scared to read it all day i
was until i heard something very wise
tonight
life is unpredictable
not everything is in our control but as
long as we're with the right people we
can handle anything so i'd like to
receive this news
with all of you quoted me okay here we
go
well from the look on my face i'm sure
you can guess what it says
no we have no idea at all just tell us
you monster
blackstone hill
oh no
blackstone hill farms
jake this was a mistake we have to get
landon on the stand now what why and how
would you describe the lieutenant he
works for hawkins he put the money in
the accounts
melanie hawkins was the most honorable
cop i ever worked with and the only
reason i am here is because of that man
jake peralta he offered me 300 000 to
lie and say that she set him up
okay okay this is bad this is really bad
but just remember
we are not going to jail we didn't do it
we're innocent guilty on all charges
oh
guilty
very cool
cool
cool
cool
you